if you want to reach me on the internet
by the way
uh you can find me on twitter girl code
with you
is my handle so
this talk is a bit of a departure from
previous talks that i've given and
that's because there's
no code in this talk um but
you know that doesn't mean that this
code this talk isn't about code
it is it's just it's about how code
makes us
feel and what those feelings mean
for us as people and for our work as
programmers
it's a subject that we don't really talk
about very often
because more often than not we're really
told that
emotions don't belong in software
engineering
you know just the zeros and ones ma'am
no
feelings involved and i remember
as a junior engineer learning to avoid
the phrase
i feel because it meant that
no matter how technical the words were
that followed that phrase
what i said was less valuable and
that's really how subtle this bias
towards logic can be in our field
and sometimes it's down right explicit
you know i'm active on twitter and i
actually see this
mentioned often like this sentiment of
code is logic emotions should not be
involved
and i should be really clear here that i
am not advocating for
emotions over logic so emotions they
uh influence how we perceive perceive
the world around us
feelings are not facts and acting on
emotions alone really isn't a good idea
and we know this you know this is part
of why we d
distrust our emotions i think that's
kind of at the heart of this logic
versus emotions debate
you know you've likely experienced what
it means to have your emotions
take over or distort a situation
but that doesn't mean that logic is the
answer
so feelings aren't facts but feelings
aren't irrelevant emotions have a
purpose
you know emotions are a feature not a
bug
you know even the unpleasant emotions
the ones
we try to avoid the most
like anxiety or worry you know these are
subsets of fear and fear is a clarifier
you know fear can tell you that
something isn't right something is amiss
or what about anger you know anger can
actually
protect us it can tell us when a
situation
is unjust it can push us to fight for
change
and you know that doesn't mean that
anger is good a hundred percent of the
time
or fear but i want us to acknowledge
that
these emotions can be both helpful and
harmful if we don't
acknowledge that we can fall into this
trap of
either or thinking so either anger is
helpful
or it's harmful either we choose logic
or we choose emotion zero or one
now in either or thinking we see two
opposing options
and nothing else and when we're
evaluating
logic and emotions we often fall into
this pattern of thinking
you know you've probably heard that
decision making should be logical
that emotions need to be removed from
that equation
that's choosing one of the extremes
logic or emotion
you need to lock one out emotions to use
the other
logic in the words of professor trelawny
neither can live while the other
survives so
it's voldemort or it's harry but it's
not both
and that's fine for fiction but it
really doesn't work like that
in the real world and
you know what i'm guilty of this i'm
guilty of believing
that i could neatly separate the
rational
from the emotional but then i learned
about elliot
so like with most psychological studies
elliot
is not elliot's real name we we don't
know his real name
but we do know that elliott had a brain
tumor
in his frontal lobe and we also know
that when the tumor
was removed there was a peculiar side
effect
so elliot's emotions were impaired
now cognitively elliot understood that
he used to have
strong feelings but now he just really
felt nothing
and this isn't why elliot is a famous
case study
his case is actually famous because the
surgery came
with another side effect and that was
impaired decision making so elliot
couldn't even make the smallest decision
his intelligence hadn't changed his
logic
was not impaired he could come up with
various options
for a given scenario but he struggled to
actually make
the decision a blue pen or a black pen
would mean hours of contemplation for
him
now antonio dimazio is a neuroscientist
who studied elliot's case
and he theorized that the impairment in
emotion
and the impairment and decision making
were connected
so this is known as the somatic marker
hypothesis
and in an effort not to bend our brains
because it is
much more involved than what i'm about
to say
i would summarize it as making a
decision
is much harder when you don't know how
you feel
about the outcome and that
how you feel about the outcome might be
a known
conscious feeling or it could be
unconscious
so feelings can act as guides in our
decision making
process emotion conscious or not
helps to filter out possibilities
and for me learning about this was a
huge relief
because i tend to feel really
instinctual about decisions
you know i won't be able to explain why
something feels like the right or wrong
decision
until maybe later on and this happens
a lot with code i can look at some code
and i get a feel for it
before i actually dig into it and i
really think that happens as you gain
experience in this field but for a long
time
i really really struggled with those
feelings
because remember i wasn't supposed to be
having feelings at
all and a hundred percent not about code
so i kept trying to separate the
feelings out
you know but after learning about
elliott and the fact that our emotions
can really help us
in decision making you know i felt more
comfortable
leaning into those instincts those
feelings
which is a really good thing because
what we do
is made better when we feel you know the
code we write isn't written
in a vacuum we're not programming in a
logic bubble
you know i want the work i put out to
feel good you know to myself and to
others
whether that's the co-workers i share a
code base with
or the end user and the longer i've
spent in software engineering
the more i've relied on feelings to
guide technical decisions
because i want a code base that feels
like a joy
to work at you know i want to craft
component apis that feel
open and flexible i want to hear
about how an abstraction makes you feel
are you frustrated
what if we tried it like this does that
feel
better you know i genuinely want to know
because i believe how we feel about code
changes how we work
and a really great example of this is
error messages
so we know from research that error
messages that are human readable
contextual and clear are less
frustrating
and result in shorter debugging sessions
we also know that the messages sentiment
matters
so in a study where programmers received
either
neutral positive or negative error
messages
those that received the negative
messages attempted
fewer repeated solutions and were
significantly less likely to finish
the task i don't even need to explain
that
further do i because we have all been
that programmer
the one muttering at our screen our
screen
maybe threatening the computer with some
creative
language happens to us all
and that's because debugging is an
emotional task
so i i love debugging but as i learned
from this twitter poll
not everyone does i i was so surprised
by this
i did not expect debugging to get like a
measly little
9.4 percent but when i think about
the emotional quality of these different
coding tasks
you know this makes sense and it also
makes sense
that we would want to avoid a task that
needs such
high levels of emotion regulation
so the more emotions involved the more
we need to
regulate those emotions like sometimes i
get
intensely involved in solving a bug
it is frustrating me i am getting
overwhelmed
but i don't do the thing i should do
which is take
a break but when i can feel that
frustration getting to an unhealthy
level
a level that's going to actually prevent
me from problem solving
i need to be able to recognize that and
take
the break that's regulation
or if we want a more official definition
the handbook of psychology of aging
defines
emotion regulation as any action
conscious or not that alters the
violence and intensity
of a current emotional experience or is
initiated
for the purpose of altering future
emotional experiences
so what i'm doing in the previous
example
is i'm decreasing the intensity of the
emotional experience
i'm frustrated i need to lessen that
feeling
and the first step is to get some space
between you
and what is causing the frustration so
i'm getting away from my computer
and then the second step is engaging in
an activity that's going to be the
opposite
of that emotion so for frustration i'm
likely to go for
a nice relaxing walk about town and a
stroll
um i'm going to talk a bit more about
that
but first i i want to be clear that
emoji
emotion regulation is not about stopping
the emotion emotions are not
a tap you can turn on and off
and i think that's often what we want to
do you know what we think
we should be doing but that's an
unreasonable
expectation for ourselves and for others
we actually have little direct control
over our emotions on a biological level
so in doing research for this talk i had
the
wonderful task of reading the emotional
brain
by neuroscientist joseph ledoux and his
research is focused on emotions and
consciousness
that it's a fascinating read we actually
know
so much more about the science of
emotions than i previously thought
we know for example that our cognitive
system
so thoughts reasons and facts
is separate from our emotional system
and we know that our brains are wired
so that the connections from our
emotional system to the cognitive system
are stronger than the inverse
connections
and this explains why emotions are able
to
flood our thoughts but our thoughts have
little influence on our emotions
so i can think stop feeling frustrated
stop feeling anxious feel happy
but those thoughts are really unlikely
to change how i feel
now that doesn't mean that i'm not able
to influence
how i feel you know i can i can watch a
film
i can go to a comedy show listen to
music
spend time with people i love we might
lack
direct control over emotions but we can
influence them indirectly we can't
change our emotional state with
internal thoughts but we can and we do
change them
with external actions so
if i go back to the debugging
frustration example
i use external actions as a method to
regulate that emotion
so step one i physically removed myself
from the stimuli that caused the
frustration
and then i mentioned the step two right
this is where i actively engage in an
action
that is the opposite of what i'm feeling
so a relaxing walk
and this by the way was not guess work
this was actually based on how our
brains
operate since we can't
think ourselves out of or into an
emotion
we can use that strong connection from
the emotional system to the cognitive
system
to help regulate the emotion we
introduce new emotions
emotions that are the opposite of what
we're feeling
and this works but it's it's not going
to be very quick
okay so again we're not stopping that
initial emotion we want to regulate
but over time it's going to decrease as
our emotional system
process processes the newer
opposing emotion
so what i've described here is opposite
to emotion action
or sometimes just it's called opposite
action
and it's an emotion regulation method
that's taught in
dialectical behavior therapy abbreviated
as dbt
and that type of therapy is focused on
providing skills to manage emotions
these skills and the methods involved in
teaching them
like right emotion regulation and
opposite action
these are based on evidence you know
what we know about how the brain
processes emotions and there's another
skill
mindfulness that is taught in dbt
mindfulness is a bit of a buzzword these
days
you know thanks to the rise of
meditation apps like headspace
and calm but mindfulness doesn't come
from meditation alone mindfulness is
a state of active open attention to the
present
so meditation is one of the examples of
practicing that active open attention
but there are some other maybe more
subtle options
like yoga and what we're attempting to
do
with mindfulness is to bring some
consciousness
to an unconscious state
emotions are an unconscious state when
we're aware of what we're feeling
that's actually us bringing
consciousness to that unconscious state
it's like breathing how often are you
conscious of your breath but you're
doing it
whether you think of it or not and it's
the same
with our emotions all emotions start as
unconscious automatic responses to
stimuli
sometimes we're aware of those responses
sometimes you can think of emotions
as icebergs ninety 90 is under the water
unseen now mindfulness can help us
become
more conscious of these unconscious
emotions
some of them you know that's really the
best that we can do
and it takes practice so
what mindfulness asks us to do is to
pause
and to examine what is happening in the
moment
i found that pausing can help me
identify
how i feel in a situation you know where
i might be too
distracted to notice identifying
emotions
can be difficult so i want to share
with you how i do this and it's mostly
through recognizing the physical side of
emotions all emotions cause
physiological changes and i i find this
really fascinating
these physical changes are actually
universal
we all have an idea of what it means to
physically experience
certain emotions so sadness
is often described as a weight
it tends to reside in our chest and in
our shoulders
happiness is akin to like a tingling
sensation
kind of like a like a fizzy soda and it
tends to like spread
throughout the body
and this is why if you take nothing else
away from this talk
i want you to know that there is value
in feeling
your feelings what we feel can be
unpleasant those physical changes
can be really uncomfortable and since we
can't turn off our emotions with the
flick of a switch
we're often left to deal with the
physical sensations
for longer than we'd like you know for
me
this has resulted in suppressing
emotions i didn't want to feel
suppressing is like dimming down the
light on consciousness
you know you distract yourself from that
emotional sensation
but it's still there and what i found
was
that the more i did this the harder it
became
to identify emotions later on
which meant i had a harder time
recognizing that i needed to regulate
an emotion and it just wasn't healthy
so deciding to actively engage with my
feelings
sit with them feel their physical
presence
you know not to be dramatic but it
really was life-changing for me
it gave me more information about myself
how i felt about situations i was in
and how to regulate those feelings
the truth is that we don't take physical
symptoms
of emotions very seriously emotions can
cause
physical pain studies have even shown
that you can take
aspirin to help with emotional pain
but we don't treat emotional wounds like
wounds
wounds get first aid emotional pain
we tell people to shrug it off ignore it
don't take it personally but what would
happen
if we treated those wounds with
emotional first aid
so before i leave you today i want to
take you through an example of what it
means to
apply some emotional first aid and
you're going to recognize a lot of
concepts that we've already talked about
in this talk as we go through this
now the example that i've chosen is a
rejected code review
oh god i chose this on purpose because
you know whether we want to admit it or
not
code reviews can be the source of
emotional turmoil
you know we created a thing and now
we're being told it's not good enough
or we made a silly mistake or i don't
know name
a million other little things that can
make us feel not so great
even if our reviewers are kind criticism
can
hurt and that's because criticism can
feel like rejection
and rejection is one of the most painful
emotions
brain scans show that activated regions
when we
experience rejection are the same
regions
that activate when we feel physical pain
and in studies of rejection participants
rated their pain as
significant even if the scenario
did not seem proportionate to the
feeling like
true story being left out of a game of
catch
with two strangers
rejection is this painful because we
need
community we need it to survive we need
it to thrive
rejection puts that at risk we are
primed to protect ourselves against it
to go into warning mode
when it happens so when our code is
criticized
it can hurt even when we know
it shouldn't that doesn't mean that it's
not a wound worth treating
okay so what's our treatment plan
well our first step is that we don't
take any action at all
remember that mindfulness asks us to
pause
so that we can examine what is happening
in the moment
so don't take any action don't respond
take a moment for yourself just pause
now learning that i could pause not
respond not take any action
and take some time for myself that has
been a
transformative lesson for me pausing is
really
an act of self-care it is taking the
time
that you need now
during this pause we need to ask
ourselves some questions
first we need to identify what we're
feeling what is the feeling
well we know that we're hurt
but maybe we don't know the exact thing
that we're feeling
um so this is a good time to
feel how you physically feel see if that
registers with you about any emotions
uh see if that comes to mind rejection
often feels
like a very sharp pain in the chest
uh sometimes it can feel like your
stomach has dropped out of your body
oh it's very very uncomfortable um
identifying what you're feeling giving
it a name
it's just a really big help um sometimes
i also
turn the attention to the thoughts that
i'm having i might write them down
even when they're really unpleasant
thoughts and
in the example of a code review that got
rejected that i might be feeling hurt
about
you know i might notice that i'm worried
if i belong on my team
i'm worried i'm not doing well enough um
and i can sort of see that start to be
like i'm gonna get rejected from my
community
and that's that's me feeling rejected
now the other thing that we really have
to decide is
if what we're feeling is proportional to
the situation
so i mentioned earlier that you know
feelings aren't facts but they're not
irrelevant
they can give you a lot of information
just because you're feeling something
doesn't mean that it it's proportional
to the situation you know a code review
you know if we think about that
logically it shouldn't cause
that much pain so we know that we need
to regulate it you know if we see that
our emotions are not proportional to the
situation we know that we need to do
something with them
help decrease them and make ourselves
feel better
and similar to before i'm going to
choose the opposite to emotion action
which means that first i need to
identify what the opposite emotion
is now rejection lowers our sense of
self-worth
and it puts our feeling of belonging at
risk
so i need something that is the opposite
of that i need to increase my self-worth
and i need to feel feelings of social
connection and then the last step is
that you know i need to make a plan for
how to replenish those feelings um that
might be
spending time with friends if you're
able to uh call a loved one to chat
um even interacting with others via
online gaming
can be a social experience that can
replenish us
so that's a hundred percent valid as
well whatever you can do
to replenish those feelings
so to recap we paused
we took some time to identify what we
were feeling
we leveled it we decided how
proportionate it was and that helps us
know how
much we need to regulate it um and then
we actually made a plan
to regulate it and these are just some
basic steps you can always take
now all of these are actually really
super hard to do
i know i made them sound very simple um
but they take
a lot of practice and so everything i've
talked about today
you can go further with all of this and
so the last thing i want to leave you
with is just
some resources for you some books that i
read in preparation for this talk some
books that i've read on my journey
and i hope that they help you thank you
all so much
you